[Music]
and welcome back to another episode of
the careful boys
and we got mr walter hung in the
building what's up walter how are you
doing man good man how you doing i'm
good nice to meet you walter nice to
meet you raiders i'm sorry i you know
i'm a huge fan it sucks
[Laughter]
devastated i like the matching hats show
i had to put this on for walter thank
you thank you i just say sorry they just
lost raiders always lose i thought
they're doing good this year or
something huh it's just
a lot in life bro it's it's the year's
over for them it's rams bengals now so
yeah well on the 13th
yes sir
one more ready to go dancers know a lot
more about pop culture than i thought
get the [ __ ] out of you that was a close
game last one yeah i was at the
conference championship is fantastic are
you serious i have seen tickets which
ones uh the rams get the [ __ ] out was
that a blast or what it was awesome i
mean sofi is awesome if you've never if
you've never been to a football stadium
and you go you'll be amazed but if
you've been to other football stadiums
you'll be even more amazed really really
we're sulfite so if it's an inglewood
yeah so basically they're caucasianizing
inglewood yeah
where they call it gentrification but
they're caucasianizing it they're kind
of like that better yeah they're kind of
like asian right yeah i can relate to
that more yeah englewood used to be um
like a lot of japanese too in japanese
and black oh yeah more black now yeah
but they're they're slowly but surely
caucasianizing it oh wow
that's what they're saying for the
stadium to to develop and they're
bringing in more condos and they're
basically pricing them so high that yeah
minorities can't live there damn yeah
and when they build it it's always like
hey you guys gotta [ __ ] go we're
bulldozing this [ __ ] so yeah we bought
all this [ __ ] you gotta go [ __ ] go
okay that's what always happens always
happens yeah and then like people
complain and then they forget because
the rap the neighborhood changes yeah
and then so far it looks it just looks
great too like bts was there oh that's
where they had the concert those tickets
i i got nosebleed tickets and i was able
to sell them for uh nine hundred dollars
holy oh you're flipping btsd no you are
ahead of the curve i was flipping yeah
cause as season ticket holders we we had
second dibs
first we usually get first dibs but
second dibs because bts fans are army's
crazy yeah so army got first like the
vip army got first dibs then season
ticket holds that second dibs so it's
all these middle aged men wait football
season tickets get second dips to an uh
solfi they helped me out when i owed uh
money to the irs nice you probably paid
for one [ __ ] light in sofa probably
if you have joe if you have the sofi
credit card i believe and if you get
season tickets you can cut in line what
yeah
they had this to give a separate line
where you don't have to wait to get in
oh it's not even a separate line you
just get to cut hold up your card
seriously can you point to people and
laugh at them as you go by i you know
i've i i've heard it's a separate line
but the way they were it sounds like you
can just cut and i bet to avoid fights
because people will point and laugh
they will point in lab i like to turn
and just go stop being [ __ ] poor
as you wear your raider's jersey yeah
yeah yeah big time yeah what makes you
like the rams have you always liked the
rams no so when you know the rams were
here originally
yeah they were in anaheim originally but
i wasn't i wasn't a fan then yeah but
then when they moved i was like i'm
gonna be a fan we used to have two
football teams rams and raiders right
yes yeah when they were the greatest
show on turf were you a fan then no i
mean like i mean like i was like it was
cool to watch yeah but um cause because
of st louis thing you're like [ __ ] these
guys for now yeah and then when they
moved back i was i wouldn't be a fan
they're going to be they're going to be
here
and so i got season tickets from the
beginning from when they first um
arrived and how that's benefited me is
is none
they don't give us anything man we can't
get super bowl tickets because people
are like oh you're going to get super
bowls like six thousand
prices went down super bowl's here this
year yeah and that's so far and the rams
are playing this is the second year in a
row
where the home team is hosting super
bowl it's only happened twice in nfl
history this last year was the other
time oh really
my buddy went to that super bowl he
spent like 60 g's for just him and his
mom to go whoa
60. he's a big bucks fan yeah 6-0 oh
yeah b that's nothing to him he's a
[ __ ] ethereum whale he doesn't care
do it no i'll tell you so okay 60 000
because that probably includes travel
hotel and all that right so my friend
brought up a good point if you're in la
and you're a rams fan and or a super
bowl fan it's best to go now because who
knows when we're in the super bowl again
yeah never right yeah and then if you're
a rams fan what what's the chances that
if we do get it again the rams will be
there yeah so there's that and we don't
have to pay for hotel and plane travel
and all food and all that we're just
going from home so you're going for sure
i'm gonna do my best to go how much are
you willing to spend my my heart says
dude you could do 10 15 right are you
serious
yeah but then my mind goes dirty what
you just said are you serious dude
you're down to pay 10 15 g's no see
maybe once in a lifetime that's true it
was pretty crazy my heart is like yo yes
but my mind's like yo i think you need
to calm down so
i'm like i'm one of those i want to wait
until it gets lower because like my i'm
not going to get my seats because my
seats i checked um when the super
tickets first went on sale they were 10
to 15 grand for my seats i was like nope
what so you got to get two that's 20 to
30 grand i'm like that's a car you're
not going to go by yourself well i can't
go on myself dude you can't go by
yourself you gotta go with friends i
can't i've gone to games by myself like
movies by yourself and stuff you can
cheer because everyone around you pretty
much season ticket holders yeah and so
you they they know you stuff you cheer
you high five but it's not the same yeah
because a part of you
yeah you still feel like a loser which
[ __ ] you're bringing that's it's on
sunday sunday i'm gonna bring sunday
yeah i'm gonna make sundays wait she's
putting out too if you're taking the
[ __ ] super bowl if you're season
ticket holder do you guys all know each
other like do you see each other in
every game yeah we see each other it's
like exclusive club yeah and what's
funny is is that like you rarely ask for
people's names because you know you're
not going to remember yeah so it's just
more like hey what's up man like how you
doing and that's it like there's no like
i'm cool with you i'm very cool with
that yeah i love that how much is a
season ticket it depends where your
seats are mine's in the end zone because
i love the madden view oh cool so i i'm
at the second level from the top and i
love the mata because you can see the
plays matriculate like who's open you
can see i love that because when you're
on the 50-yard line which is the view of
tv yeah you can't see the plays
matriculate you know you only see them
run and you don't know if they're open
but where i'm sitting you know exactly
when someone's open yeah you know you're
[ __ ] yeah dude i got to see lamar
jackson two years ago at the coliseum
when they killed it the ravens killed us
you could see him running basically
straight and his jukes are so fast dude
defenders are just like whoa where did
he just go so what we see on tv is so
different from really sucks
and you see the fight for every yard the
fight for every yard is so fascinating
in real life because like a yard on tv
just looks like just get it but in real
life you're like holy [ __ ] that's so
hard like they go to war just to move it
like that yeah and you see how big
everyone is because video slows things
down so like basketball you can't truly
appreciate how fast they are unless
you're in the first few roles and
they're tall
dude i went to a [ __ ] laker game
because my friends uh dad's a sushi chef
for uh uh those skybox guys oh nice and
then so we got these tickets and at that
time i still don't know [ __ ] about
basketball but then i was like
why the hell are they so tall they're
not this tall tv they're like giant is
this big on tv yeah i saw kareem
abdul-jabbar at a cheesecake factory and
that [ __ ] looked as big as one
of the columns you know how cheesecake
always has those columns he was it was
like watching a column move dude
i saw dr jay in person in vegas and you
know you know at vegas they have those
like plastic trays that hold the dollar
coins oh yeah like when you play at
poker at a table yeah but it's all coins
like they have the dollar coins they
don't really do coins now because it's
all like hard i grabbed by the coins
yeah but they had they had a tray that
carried coins yeah and so for me i'd
probably hold i could barely hold it one
hand dr j i went to emmy dr j good to
meet you he shook my hand while he was
holding that trick
he held it with his like ring and pinky
finger and then he shook my hand with
his index and middle finger and it still
felt like a real hand yeah that's so
good handshake that's how big these
dudes are and what's scary is is like if
you slap one of them and you run away
they'll wait a few seconds and they'll
still catch you
with two steps yeah
dude on to tecumpo on 60 minutes i don't
know how they knew to ask him but they
go how many steps does it take for you
to get from one end baseline to the
other end yeah he goes six that's so
crazy no
six steps on a basketball court on a
basketball court
based on the base like six steps they
had a crazy statistic like that with
lebron
science with him they made him do the
same thing and he can he could travel
from one end to the other in like two
seconds you know what i just realized
i'm [ __ ] small dude
i'm [ __ ] small you're a point guard
you're a point guard
it's the height and the speed and the
explosiveness so when they're pushing
they're already they're not landing
until like over here are they like dream
running yeah you know when you dream run
you [ __ ] float yeah yeah
have you played basketball with khalifa
yeah but he takes it easy on me yeah but
even when you play with him so we have a
friend that used to play in the pro-am
league in like south america and even
for someone like him and he's not even
he wouldn't be considered a tall bastard
i'm taller than him yeah he's like 6-3
but if he could like he he only makes
maybe needs like one or two steps from
the three-point line to dunk dude like
only be like two steps and if the ball
is flying up like this guy's like
getting his waist up to where the rim is
yeah and then he floats a little higher
yeah yeah wings come out and just like
today's video is brought to you by
audible it's a one app place where you
can get all of your audio entertainment
and you know i drive from vegas to here
all the time and back and forth because
that's like a four hour drive it is a
four hour drive so i like to listen to
things that help me grow and also when
i'm at home i don't have time to read
because i have like this very small
human being that takes up a lot of my
time babies the easy way is through
audiobooks and i've been checking out
this book
how to win friends and influence people
it's one of the most recommended books
out there because it actually teaches
you how to not talk at people but how to
talk like with people and that's one of
the books that i've been listening to
and when it's uh
when they use the original author's
voice
i always i always really like it because
it feels
like way more personal i like to listen
to audible audiobooks while i'm working
out because i feel like i'm multitasking
oh wow i'm just like yeah man give me
that pump but at the same time it's like
talking about you know buddhism or
something relaxing or whatever it is but
they have more than just audio books
they also have a podcast
they have a comedy performances they
have many different types of media you
can also enjoy and if you're a member
you can check out one title of book
every single month the best sellers the
newest ones you can oh it's the the new
one that came out that everyone's
listening or talking about you can get
caught up on that and if you're a new
member you can check it out for 30 days
for free for free so if this sounds
interesting to you and you'd like to
have all of your audio entertainment in
one app make sure you go check them out
go to audible.com off the record or text
off the record of 500 500 that's
audible.com off the record or text off
the record to 500 500. what celebrities
did you see
that's so far yeah so they that's one
thing with sofa i don't know if other
stadiums do this or when they can't but
la is so fine they always show the
celebrities of the games they they just
put them on the jumbotron
so the guy from entourage was there i
never know his name but turtle manager
turtle oh e crazy
yeah he was there and he i guess he's
bffs with uh leo dicaprio because leo
dicaprio was there
and then um nina dobrev
from um the vampire diaries she was
there
um dr dre is usually there he's doing
the super bowl
um
who else was there did you see mayor
garcetti
everyone's mad at him because he didn't
wear magic johnson yeah yeah and he said
he held his breath he's like oh the
picture was like that is the funniest
[ __ ] nikki just sent me that he said he
held his breath while taking a picture
with magic
which by the way that's [ __ ] up too
because if you remember like when magic
came out with hiv people are certain
players who wouldn't even play with
magic so saying like i took a picture of
magic but don't worry i didn't breathe i
know right [ __ ] hilarious dude on so
many levels
what happens after you hold your breath
you have a large exhale i know i really
feel like maybe or does he put the mask
on and goes
i
think
my life source
you know they weren't wearing i like
that if the mayor says that then are we
allowed to you know are we allowed to go
to a restaurant if you don't have a map
i'm just going to hold my breath from
here to the table yeah yeah as you're
telling them
walter did you get to watch it with any
celebrities or were there any
celebrities with you oh no no no you you
asked me with me no no okay i got your
beat then because uh
so i was at this restaurant at the red
rock casino with buddy of mine who's in
town and no [ __ ] we just get there right
and we we look to our left and it's
[ __ ] captain america no way i
watched the wreck in the bar i watched
the rams game with chris evans no no no
steve rogers in america the captain
america the new one chris evans no what
are you talking about the new one oh
anthony anthony mackie he hasn't he
hasn't seen that yeah oh that's a
spoiler he's just one of them caught up
on the other [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'm
sorry i just spoiled it big time
okay
uh being the new counselor came out like
over a year yeah
oh he's the new one now the new cap yeah
hey if you have if you haven't watched
it yet it's too late like did you watch
the avengers end game no of course not i
watched the first 30 minutes oh my god
but robert downey jr is trying to like
you know trying to live a regular life
always at the end where they where he
passes it to him yes oh okay yeah and
then they did a whole show after that on
disney plus the whole show called
i have a question bart do you know
there's a chinese marvel superhero who
jackie chan oh shanxi yeah yeah man okay
you knew that one right i just wasn't
sure this will set man okay
no because i was re-watching some of the
other stuff like so taika's been stuck
on spider-man right he's been stuck on
spider-man for like forever and then
finally i'm like you can watch can we
watch something else so i've introduced
him to wolverine and one of the
wolverine ones there's uh agent zero was
played by daniel henning right i'm like
why the [ __ ] isn't this guy the first
asian superhero this guy is [ __ ] cool
he actually has no actual as opposed to
who he actually has super powers like as
we always say shane she doesn't really
have to you know
it's kung fu right this guy actually
shoots [ __ ] like some crazy [ __ ] like
john wick he can he can uh slice bullets
who can that's that dude that's deadpool
oh i know i thought it wasn't their
scene where damn honey comes and then
they shoot him and he like slices the
bullet and then it goes this like i
believe that sounds like a lot of movies
i believe the reference in the wolverine
movie though is deadpool who does that
aka ryan reynolds blade does that too
right yeah
i don't know
but the thing is like when i think
superhero i think a gimmick and and uh
agent zero has the gimmick you know like
every superhero has a game she has 10
rings and he has the whole father thing
that and he has a cool jacket he's a
[ __ ] signature he has a cool a sick
story but there's no like the thing you
know sounds like you're not trying to
support asian americans dude yeah what
the heck man no i i got to tell you guys
i know why daniel henny didn't make it
why he's too pretty dude he's too pretty
man they they didn't want him to be that
successful like they being the powers
that be they're like this dude is too
good looking he's going to take white
women he's going to take our women
as opposed to who who who's who's put
there to uh so they got simulated
okay just i'm not i'm not not a fan of
simu but he's not the best looking guy
in the world you know he's not like
william lee he's not you know daniel
henny he's not those guys man i just
gotta who do you think would have been a
better shane chief
i thought
if will you knee was born 10 years later
i thought he would have been a better
[ __ ] because he was in a lecture
actually he was the bad guy in electra i
thought he would have been better are
you like are you saying that probably a
hundred percent would have been a way
better you'd have been great as if bobby
like start they started out with bobby
and then he got the powers and then he
turned into william lee
like shazam like
shazam like [ __ ] hulk yeah because
that you know what that happened to
william lee in one of the james bond
movies
the guy got positive surgery and they
turned into rick yoon oh yeah rick you
sexy bond villain the diamond face dude
didn't make it for other reasons i don't
want to get into what other reasons
tokyo drift he [ __ ] made it he's not
the
like the
most warm person i'll just say that
diplomatic he's not the warmest guy in
the world
i like that a little bit more
like carl his brother like he's hard to
work with on set but super cool carl's
super cool i don't know whose brother is
the younger brother was in this movie
where they were like in the wilderness
like a river wilderness i think i'll say
j-lo was in the movie
anaconda i think i think it was anaconda
i
think
oh dude he was ice cube he played ice
cube in that movie he by the way
fun fact if you have a denzel washington
movie like question there's your guy he
loves denzel i'm a big denzel just just
as the day progresses any denzel trivia
we'll talk about anything yeah i love
denzel what tv which tv show you started
you know it's uh
fresh prince of bel-air
i'll give you a hint it was a hospital
drama it was on nbc days of our
a few guys maybe you lives on tv for us
yeah it's staying elsewhere so you're
[ __ ] with me
damn it this guy knows denzel denzel and
george cooney got their start in tv and
they're the few they're the few that
made jump made the jump to feature films
oh yeah er right yeah george clooney
actually never renegotiated a contract
er was number one from the get-go so a
lot of the actors renegotiated their
contracts they wanted more money george
was i think 90 000 per episode at the
time he just stayed with it all four
years
then he left he left the show he never
negotiated his deal remember what he
said when he left he's like i'm i'm
batman i'm about to [ __ ] rule the
universe
his financial advisor told my batman he
was you don't have to work again after
batman the money that came in you have
to work again and then he said from that
point he decided i'm going to choose now
who i work with and what i want to work
on yeah that was that was the point that
that was like the divergence in his
career underrated clooney movie three
kings i love that movie very good is
that one in the desert yeah fun fact
about that john ridley wrote that john
really wrote um 12 years a slave won the
oscar for he also wrote the classic
undercover brother oh that's a great
movie really gone really was a stand-up
comic yeah
he also wrote for freshman to bel-air
dude that cat wrote three kings he won
three kings
this is what happened this is a fun pack
so david russell who directed three
kings is very very very difficult to
work with uh he's known to yell at
people he all did a pa george felt sorry
for him and he yelled that david goes
you cannot treat people that way hit
george p aside he goes hey look why
don't you go to my trailer i have some
fan mail why don't you just separate it
however you feel just take some time
that's george that's george clooney
great guy nice guy he made the guy
separate george clooney go do my mail
i'm a great man
yeah just figure it out the thing was
just go do something else because he
just got yelled at by by david russell
well david russell decided i don't like
really script the way it is so i'm going
to change it so there's a wga thing if
you change the x amount x percentage of
your script now the original writer no
longer is a screenwriter the other
person is so david russell became the
screenwriter so it was story by john
ridley screenplayed by david russell
yeah
and then um
that tried to happen to him again i
think in 12 years like because malcolm
is a malcolm lead director 12 years a
slave and they had it they had a real
like big fight about it because he tried
to change when he script and he's like
no this is not going to happen again and
really won the oscar and if you see that
clip of malcolm
when he wins he just goes
[Laughter]
[Music]
so much drama behind this hollywood
drama
ridley is one of those stand-up guys
because he used to be a comic and he
told he told me because he used to work
on he used to be a writer on third watch
i was at the production company that
produced their watch and he told me he
quit stand up this is when he quit stand
up he had just won the montreal comedy
festival he goes to hollywood improv and
goes hey can i get some time i just won
the macho comedy festival they're like
why don't you give us a call and we'll
let you know
he quit stand up right there because i
was already a producer martin at the
time wow why do i need this wow that's
how difficult stand up comedy is so
those of you out there listening you're
like i'm gonna try comedy because i'm
funnier than walter or whatever [ __ ] you
go ahead go ahead quick go ahead dude
who are more [ __ ] in the industry
[Music]
you